benjamin est ce que vous seriez prêt à
lui dire en face patrick timsit ce que
vous pensez de ce qu'il a dit même bien
sûr ce sera oui c'est vrai que les
propos sans ma famille c'est un truc
qu'il faut voilà ces gens ne sortent pas
mais est ce que c'est ce que vous seriez
prêt s'il est la jolie en poste de nuit
ce que je pense de lui fait d'entrée
patrick timsit
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dieu c'est maurice béjart bas
voilà on a vu tout de suite ces assauts
dit patrick timsit mais il ya une énorme
rigolade maurice merci d'être là mais de
rien un plaisir merci bon il serait un
amour d'être là et maurice ya un truc
fou je ne savais même pas il paraît
qu'il ya vraiment patrick timsit qui t'a
appelé tout à fait et quitte à laisser
un message pour nous exactement c'est
alors je vous lors que la cpc le vrai
patrick timsit
enfin pas maurice morris est le sosie de
patrick timsit d'ailleurs merci mon
résultat
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé durant
patrick timsit avait-on numéro oui et
quant aux mureaux communique
régulièrement oui et il t'a dit je sais
que tu vas chez hanouna ce soir on sait
moins qu'il ait appelé away et tu lui as
dit quoi balle que je venais ici et il
t'a dit j'ai un message pour eux tout à
fait à ben vas-y vas-y assez énorme ça
c'est fort comme un gain alors mais le
bien devant ton micro close to me là on
fait courir derrière vos de la
technologie maurice à vous l'appelez
l'accord il va nous répondre
super oui comme quoi mais oui c'est
magnifique à l'arrêt mettez bien photo
m'étais bien dans le micro le haut
parleur
cyrille janssoone partir de 4 ans
maintenant on est cool ils sont
apparemment il s'est bien foutu de sa
gueule d'ange et maurice maintenant
écoutez écoutez quoi non n'entend rien
john morris est ce que tu te le rappeler
en fait il a laissé un message sur sa
messagerie
mais ce que je peux le faire comme ça on
écoute le message qu'il avait lui même
sur sa messagerie bien pas dit c'est
parti c'est incroyable et le vrai
patrick timsit
je suis un peu de ce sont inquiètes pas
je travaillais chez phone house c'est
incroyable donc patrick timsit sur ça
mais ça c'est quand on l'appelle mais un
message un message pour vous c'est
incroyable pays-bas droit ça continue et
tourmalet il faut que la rue soit on met
un ça va
sans mes collègues m'ont patrie bon
retard mais ça ils ont craint pas l'eau
diminue voilà bah voila c'est vraiment
non mais c'est pas possible il est plein
d'humour mais j'adore ça s'arrête à
robin d'avatar olic batterie et maurice
sur tout cas merci jack la morinais de
rien c'est un plaisir les bains et tuer
tuer de suite voilà tu es content d'être
là oui tout à fait eh ben merci banos si
on est on est on est content de t'avoir
ont-ils condom invités car on sait qu'on
n'a jamais invité patrick en fait
j'étais sûr que s'il n'ya pas mon nom il
y en a tant que la femme était quoi la
vérité oui je peux dire est que je lui
ai envoyé aussi un mois patrick timsit
je lui avais dit regarde l'émission yes
théière way et il m'a dit je peux pas je
regarde quotidien genentech cecosida
c'est le très bon et michel a raison
alors garder après moi je préfère je
propose que c'est moi qui l'a fait mais
c'est vrai que voilà mais patrick timsit
à moi y'a pas vendre beaucoup de tickets
à ce propos la billetterie est ouverte
amedeo au théâtre du rond-point partir
dans mon lit